[Musique]
Salut les Terriens salut les caioles
très heureux de vous retrouver notre
invité principale ce soir c'est Marc
Levy
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors
Marc Levy bonsoir vous êtes ici ce soir
pour nous confirmer une information qui
circule depuis un petit moment à Paris
vous allez faire votre entrée à
l'Académie française
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je rassure tout ce qui sont en train de
s'étrangler devant leur téléviseur c'est
une blague j'espère quand même que j'ai
pas tué Jean d'Ormesson
alors Marc vous connaissez l'émission en
paix nous serons tous les deux nous
parlerons de vous de vos origines de
votre enfance de votre adolescence de
vos premiers Jobs et puis de votre
incroyable succès éditorial vous êtes
l'écrivain français le plus lu dans le
monde avec 20 millions d'exemplaires
combien acheter par votre mère
1980 alors ne pas le droit également de
votre dernier livre la première nuit
c'est la suite du premier jour vous avez
continué comme ça le deuxième jour la
deuxième nuit troisième jour dans j'y
pense alors en P2 nous accueillerons
deux nouveaux invités pour commentaires
avec nous l'actualité de la semaine
Aurélie Filippetti député PS de la
Moselle Aurélie nous parlera de la
grande spécialité de son département le
chômage
toujours en paix de nous recevrons
Dominique Farrugia Dominique Farruggia à
qui le président de la République
Nicolas Sarkozy vient de remettre la
Légion d'Honneur alors évidemment il y a
beaucoup de gens qui ont été choqués par
cette décoration pourquoi pas Stevie
boulet
en P3 après Guillon et le zapping nous
accueillerons notre invité du samedi 20h
ce soir Cécile Hernandez Cervelo pour
ses livres témoignages sur la sclérose
en plaques Cécile nous révélera que
l'avantage d'avoir la même maladie que
Dominique Farrugia s'est construit un
peu plus dans les soirées de gala
voilà l'émission
[Musique]
alors Marc Lili rebonsoir donc on voit
quasiment jamais à la télévision c'est
vrai pourquoi vous êtes là parce que
la première émission de télévision je
l'ai fait avec vous Rivera trive gauche
et que cette semaine c'est des je fais
des dix ans ben voilà donc voilà je me
suis dit voilà voilà une bonne raison
d'être là alors vos deux livres paru en
2009 se sont écoulés après de 2 millions
d'exemplaires donc ce qui fait 20
millions 10 ans traduit en 41 langues
vous êtes le plus grand écrivain
français devant Victor Hugo
un mètre 83 je crois que s'il était au
plus grand encore voilà comment vous
faites vous dites je raconte l'histoire
à mon meilleur ami et un moment je vous
propose un café si après cela il me
demande la suite de l'histoire je
considère que c'est bon si je vois aux
gens que je raconte l'histoire à ce
proche que j'arrive pas à capter son
attention c'est que l'outil est pas prêt
la matrice est pas prête et voilà la
narration est simple rapide sans
fioriture stylistique accessible au plus
grand nombre c'est assumer ça c'est
volontaire ouais faire simple demande
beaucoup de travail et si vous voulez
faire plus stylé vous pourriez le faire
je n'y prendrais pas de plaisir la
liberté de ce métier c'est de regarder
ce qu'on écrit et pas de se regarder
écrire très bien voilà alors
vous venez de parler de métier vous
parlez pas tard
vous connaissez cette phrase
merveilleuse de Nino Ventura qui a
répondu large n'en suis pas encore là
et je sais où est ma place et ce que je
sais faire est-ce que je ne serai pas
faire et quand je lis un roman de
Christian Bobin d'Antoine Audouard de de
Cormac McCarthy je sais que je ne suis
pas Mozart mais ça a même interdit pas
pour autant de chanter sous la douche
[Applaudissements]
alors évidemment devant un tel succès
les critiques sont d'accord joie prose
d'aéroports vocabulaire de tout
opérateur romance guimauve débiter au
maître enfin alors pour vous
dites-vous c'est de la jalousie et
surtout du snobisme ça n'est pas sans me
rappeler ce qu'il s'est passé dans la
musique au début du 20e siècle quand le
jazz est arrivé il y avait des critiques
musicaux qui disaient mais c'est pas de
la musique ça c'est une barbarie dans la
dans la littérature on veut à la fois
dans les journaux parisiens dans le
nouvel homme qui d'ailleurs très
étrangement sont de gauche
et qui déteste la littérature populaire
donc c'est une contradiction qui m'a
toujours amusé il y a pas plus élitiste
que ces journaux et alors il y a un
double langage qui est quand même
étrange c'est alors on se donne bonne
figure il faut que il faudrait que les
gens lisent de plus en plus ce serait
merveilleux la lecture est en danger on
lit pas assez et dès qu'il y a un livre
qui est lu on dégoûte qui les grenades
et on essaye de dédinguer l'auteur donc
en fait c'est très difficile de vous
critiquer Marc parce que vous avez pas
de problème d'ego vous dites que l'on
dise de moi que je suis un auteur de
métro ne me dérange pas ça me fait même
extrêmement plaisir si vous dites à un
boulanger que il fait des pains au
chocolat que les gens mangent dans le
métro ça va pas le déranger et il va
vous dire mais moi vous savez les gens
les mange où ils veulent mes petits
pains au chocolat vous voyez plutôt
comme un artisan comme un artiste je
pense si un jour je disais moi que je
suis un artiste mon meilleur ami me dire
il faut qu'on parle toi et moi parce que
ça y est ça va pas bien le gardien
absolu de l'écriture c'est l'humilité et
si on perd ça alors on se regarde
d'écrire mais est-ce que vous pensez au
fond que comme des Dumas des jeunes su
enfin des grands feuilletonistes du XIXe
sont devenus aujourd'hui des classiques
est-ce que vous pensez quand même
quelque part que un jour dans quelques
décennies vos livres deviendront des
classiques écoutez j'aime mieux être un
auteur populaire de mon vivant et un
auteur célèbre de ma mort ouais vous
vous foutez de votre postérité en fait à
totalement ma grand-mère m'a dit un jour
c'est que comment les hommes peuvent
avoir envie qu'on fasse des statues à
leur effigies à croire qu'ils n'ont
jamais vu ce que les pigeons
c'est bon
alors quand on s'intéresse à votre vie
on découvre qu'en plus de tout ça
l'écriture n'était pas vraiment votre
vocation vous avez fait plein d'autres
trucs avant on va regarder un petit peu
votre vie votre famille est originaire
dismée en Turquie le travail à
grand-père ni SIM les vies de by racli a
construit le grand ascenseur d'Ismir qui
est adossé à la falaise qui relie la
partie haute et la partie basse de la
ville et qui est toujours en service où
il y en a en fait ce qui s'est passé mon
arrière-grand-père était un homme qui
avait le grand bazar de smirn il était
illettré et mais sa patience c'était la
réunion des communautés et il s'était
rendu compte que le cette séparation
entre la ville haute et la ville basse
empêchaient les personnes âgées d'aller
de la ville haute à la ville basse et il
était convaincu que la sagesse ce
véhicule est par les personnes âgées et
donc il a racheté dans les cales d'un
cargo anglais un ascenseur
et il a fait venir des ingénieurs
allemands on est au début du siècle et
il a fait construire cette ascenseur le
long de la falaise qui a fêté son
centenaire l'année dernière ça c'est
votre arrière-grand-père donc exilé à
partir de 1923 vos grands-parents seront
déportés à Auschwitz votre père sera un
héros de la résistance c'est vrai ça
vous a influencé ça s'il y a une chose
que j'ai qui m'a beaucoup influencé
c'est que j'ai compris que le
que la façon dont mon père avait gagné
la guerre
c'était pas joué pendant la résistance
c'est après qu'il a gagné
la plus grande victoire de ceux qui sont
revenus des camps la plus grande
victoire de ceux qui ont résisté à mes
yeux c'est d'avoir trouvé la force de
vivre une vie normale c'est d'avoir
trouvé la force d'être capable d'aimer
d'élever des enfants alors quand vous
êtes à l'école primaire dans le sud de
la France vous faites traiter à ses
couramment de sel juifs au moins deux
fois par jour et là vous êtes
extraordinaire si vous y voyez plutôt de
la bêtise que de l'antisémitisme et
c'était de la bêtise j'aurais eu une
tache bleue sur la joue on m'aurait
traité de salstroumpf oui bon alors
enfant vous êtes horriblement timide
toujours et alors vous aviez un
zozotement oui et je louchais
quand j'étais petit pour faire pleurer
ma mère je disais maman elles sont pas
beaux mes yeux
alors
à 15 ans vous voyez un film
extraordinaire ça s'appelle pas et
chocolat qui raconte l'histoire de
jeunes gens riches et blonds qui se
baignent nu sous le regard de Noirot
qui sont enfermés dans une espèce de
poulailler quoi derrière un grillage et
la sortie votre père vous dit de quel
côté du grillage tu veux être et vous
lui répondez je voudrais du côté on peut
le couper
et voilà et je le et je remercierai
toujours mon père de cela parce que
c'est pas ce qui m'a emmené voir ce film
et qui m'a posé cette question je suis
rentré à la Croix-Rouge 2 ans après
voilà alors à la Croix-Rouge
effectivement parallèlement à ça trois
ans d'étude de gestion à Dauphine vous
créez votre premier entreprise à ce
moment-là Logitech France ça faisait
quoi ça faisait de l'image de synthèse
en 1989 vous êtes papa de Louis donc et
alors vous lui racontez tous les soirs
une histoire et c'est comme ça qu'en
fait vous vous commencez à goûter au
truc et l'enfant est un public qui n'a
aucune pitié si c'est pas bien il dort
et puis deux si vous répétez quelque
chose que vous avez déjà dit ou si vous
reprenez pas au bon endroit donc j'avais
pris l'habitude le soir d'écrire le la
suite de l'histoire pour le lendemain
pour être le plus juste possible et puis
un jour j'ai vu que la télé était
beaucoup mieux que mes histoires à
défaut de pouvoir écrire pour l'enfant
j'ai eu envie d'écrire pour l'adulte
voilà vous écrivez pour l'adulte et
votre sœur Lorraine voit ça c'est
vachement bien elle la porte chez Robert
Laffont gros coup de bol chez Robert
Laffont il y a Suzana Léa qui est là et
qui se dit [__] ça c'est exactement le
genre de pitch que les Américains
adorent
à l'époque chez un aléa qui depuis un
grand agent international mais à
l'époque dirige le département des
droits internationaux de la font et elle
emporte le manuscrit dans ses bagages à
la foire de Francfort et c'est comme ça
que le livre le manuscrit dans les mains
de Spielberg la suite on la connaît
c'est 20 millions d'exemplaires
alors
avant de passer la suite de l'émission
je vais vous donner Marc un conseil à de
jeunes romanciers pour réussir votre
secret c'est la main sous le nom
vous savez pourquoi
à chaque fois que vous devez faire une
photo parce que ça c'est des photos
c'est pas des photos que j'ai pris dans
ma cuisine et ben je peux vous dire pour
ces quatre photos qui ont été prises à
chaque fois le photographe vous dire ce
que vous pourriez mettre la main sous le
nom c'est pas vous non ça doit faire
plus sérieux c'est parce que
le menton je dis ça pour les jeunes
romanciers il y a la barbe de trois
jours il y a la tête un peu penchée à
droite
vous pouvez nous la faire là la pause là
comme ça voilà
très bien et nous accueillons Aurélie
Filippetti bonsoir
et deux minutes au diable
alors vas-y bonsoir vous êtes
porte-parole du groupe socialiste à
l'Assemblée nationale et député PS de
Moselle en tout cas merci d'être venu ce
soir j'avais peur que le dernier moment
où on voyait une lettre pour me dire que
vous ne viendriez pas pour dénoncer ce
débat indigne de la République entre
Marc Levy et Dominique
sur la Légion d'Honneur attribué à
Dominique Farrugia par Nicolas Sarkozy
vous l'avez dénoncé sur votre sur votre
blog avec vigueur
je la porte dans les grandes occasions
ah merci
alors Aurélie vous êtes une socialiste
issue de la classe ouvrière c'est comme
une espèce en voie de disparition faut
bien changer ça change des autres oui
vos grands-parents immigrés italiens
sont venus chercher du travail dans les
mines de Lorraine votre grand-père
résistant et déporté la Gestapo est
venue le chercher au fond de la mine
avec ces deux frères et votre père
mineur de fond lui aussi
délégué syndical et militants
communistes alors vous vous étiez à
griser de l'être classique vous
commencez votre carrière comme
enseignante et puis vous bifurquez vers
la politique d'abord les Verts et
ensuite le PS alors en 2007 j'avais
soutenu Ségolène Royal en 2012
soutiendrait qui enfin n'importe qui
d'autre disons
je soutiendrai le candidat du parti
socialiste alors Martine abri évidemment
qui en ce moment mec des boucles
d'oreilles se montre un peu plus
agressive elle commence à monter dans
les dans les sondages d'ailleurs vous
qui la connaissez bien est-ce qu'elle
travaille vraiment 35 heures par semaine
35 heures à Solférino 35 heures à Lille
alors Nicolas Sarkozy a fait un malaise
vagal cet été et vous lorsque le
président est venu à Gandrange en
octobre vous avez fait un malaise vagal
aussi n'oubliez pas laisser à la droite
le monopole du malaise vagal en fait
alors votre deuxième malaise vagal parce
que quand même vous êtes une habitué du
truc c'est à l'Assemblée nationale en
pleine séance en novembre 2009 en
découvrant les chiffres du chômage
ça aurait pu être c'est vrai que là un
million de chômeurs en fin de droit
cette année c'est 100 000 personnes qui
vont basculer sur le RSA ou la location
Spécifique de Solidarité c'est énorme
c'est du Japon alors votre prochain
malaise est-ce que vous pensez que ce
sera le lundi soir en écoutant Nicolas
Sarkozy sur TF1 parce que c'est vrai que
pour une agrégé de lettres ça doit pas
être facile toutes ces fautes de
français
mais moi c'est qu'il a grandi quand même
dans les beaux quartiers donc je me
demande où il a appris à mal parler
français
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir vous êtes ici ce soir pour
pousser un coup de gueule et vous élever
contre la remise de la Légion d'honneur
par Nicolas Sarkozy à Daniela Lumbroso
ça vous choque qu'on la donne à
n'importe qui
elle a pas inventé la mouche qui pètent
à la France si ce n'est que j'ai
participé aux nul j'ai créé plusieurs
sociétés comédie Cuisine TV où j'ai créé
de l'emploi aussi je continue à le faire
puisque j'ai produit plus de 30 films et
et au-delà de ça avec UNICEF
je mets une action pour essayer de
trouver un remède à la sclérose en
plaques et ça je le fais depuis 10-15
ans de manière
cachée sans rien dire et voilà il a
voulu me récompenser j'ai trouvé ça très
sympathique mais oui on est ravi
alors tout ça donc c'est passé c'est
sympa il y avait Carla elle avait fait
quoi à manger Carla alors il y avait
plein de petits fours très bons et
qu'elle avait fait elle-même
alors vous reviendrez en mai Dominique
pour un film qui s'appelle l'amour c'est
mieux à deux super titre film réalisé
par vous avec Arnaud Lemort donc avec au
casting Clovis Cornillac Manu Payet
Virginie Efira Virginie Efira c'est pour
surfer sur le succès de canal presque
que vous l'avez que vous l'avez prise je
demande des conseils à Canal canal je
les donne et j'ai exécute pratiquement
non mais voilà je suis très content
d'avoir pu réaliser ce film et je
réalise un autre là j'espère la d'ici
deux mois c'est voilà c'est un petit
challenge contre ce que j'ai ce qu'on
peut contre la maladie ça va mieux avec
des acteurs que j'aime bien et il
s'avère que c'est faire ça plutôt pas
trop mal donc au moins je fais moins de
conneries non vous attends au mois de
mai
on passe maintenant en commentaire de
l'actualité de la semaine et c'est Yves
très rare directeur adjoint de la
rédaction du quotidien Le Figaro que
nous retrouverons en plateau après le
magnéto
[Musique]
57% des Français sont favorables à une
loi sur la burqa et pourtant le 30
juillet 2009 le figarotti trait la burqa
est un phénomène marginal en France les
policiers de la sous-direction du
renseignement intérieur estime alors que
367 femmes en France portent le voile
intégrale tu parles d'une invasion dans
le rapport les policiers expliquent que
le port du voile s'apparente à une
volonté de provoquer la société
[Musique]
on se demande bien comment 400 filles en
burqa pourrait faire peur à 65 millions
de Français mais c'était sans compter
sur la publicité que Laura accordé le
gouvernement et le MP ceci est une
alerte invasion elles peuvent dire merci
au président qui leur a fait une bonne
pub il n'y a pas de place pour la Burqa
merci Copé qui a voulu faire une loi sur
le sujet on va faire une loi
d'interdiction et à Xavier Bertrand qui
veut retirer la nationalité française à
celle qui porte la burqa la majorité est
ambitieuse pour ses élections depuis les
policiers ont refait leur compte et il y
aurait finalement en France 2000 femmes
qui portent la burqa soit
0,04% des 5 millions de musulmans
vivants en France et qui une fois de
plus se retrouve stigmatisé alors
pourquoi la majorité accorde autant
d'importance un sujet que le Figaro
lui-même considérait il y a six mois
comme un phénomène marginal et bah c'est
simple pendant qu'on parle de la burqa
la burkhale la burqa burqa la burqa pas
sa place non à la burqa au moins on ne
parle pas d'autre chose pourtant d'ici
la fin de l'année selon Pôle emploi il y
aura un million de chômeurs en fin de
droit dont 600000 ne toucheront aucune
allocation elle est chômeurs si vous
voulez qu'on parle de vous bah reste
plus qu'à enfiler une burqa
[Musique]
c'est un peu de Blacko mise en images de
Julien grappe
ultra arbançoire vous êtes directeur
adjoint de la rédaction du Figaro
éditorialise bienvenue sur le plateau de
Salut les Terriens alors la burqa
évidemment remarqué c'est vrai que c'est
encombrant une burqa on a du mal à voir
les 4 millions de chômeurs qui sont
planqués derrière quand même
est-ce que c'est un débat leur
je crois pas je crois que c'est un vrai
débat et d'ailleurs c'est un communiste
c'est André Girin qui a mis cette
question sur la table l'année dernière
on dit il y a 360 ou bien il y a 2000
femmes qui portent la burqa en France
mais quand on a supprimé la peine de
mort ça concernait très peu de gens en
France aussi et pourtant c'était une
grande avancée pour la société et pour
moi le fait que on dise qu'il faut
interdire la burqa en France c'est un
progrès pour les femmes c'est une
avancée pour les droits des femmes c'est
tout je trouve que l'argument de dire il
y a tellement d'autres problèmes le
chômage mais le chemin ça fait 25 30 ans
qui a 10% de chômeurs en France donc on
aurait rien fait d'autre que de
s'occuper du chômage et même quand on
s'en occupe on sait pas le faire donc je
pense que c'est un vrai un vrai problème
celui de la burqa et je pense qu'il faut
une loi et plus qu'une résolution vous
savez cette espèce de nouvelle
instrument qu'on nous a sorti qui sert
de pétition de principe en disant la
burqa c'est pas bien il faut qu'il y ait
une loi parce qu'il faut qu'il y ait une
il faut qu'il y a un objectif il faut
qu'il y ait une sanction et je trouve en
plus que le débat tel qu'il a été posé
en France c'est un débat sérieux il y a
une commission parlementaire qui s'est
réunie les gens de droite de gauche on
en a parlé et on en a plutôt bien parlé
je trouve
ce qui me gêne dans le débat sur la
burqa c'est
c'est de la tournure que prendre des bas
c'est à dire que pour moi les choses
sont beaucoup plus sensibles que ça il y
a pas que le débat sur la burqa le débat
sur la burqa s'inscrit en ce moment dans
une situation où la communauté musulmane
est si et systématiquement stigmatisé
pour des tas de choses il y a le
ministère de l'Identité nationale tout
ça se mélange et moi je trouve au
contraire que c'est très mal expliqué
il y a des façons peut-être plus simple
de dire les choses vous ne pouvez pas
aujourd'hui vous promener dans beaucoup
de pays musulmans en mini-jupes c'est un
code vestimentaire ça n'est pas pour
autant de la part des pays arabes une
stigmatisation de la société occidentale
c'est un code vestimentaire on vous dit
bah chez nous la minijupe ça nous gêne
on aurait pu je trouve aborder le débat
sur la burqa avec plus de diplomatie au
regard d'une communauté musulmane qu'on
a un peu trop tendance à mon avis en
France à stigmatiser et c'est ça qui me
dérange je trouve que ça manque de
délicatesse et d'intelligence vis-à-vis
d'une communauté qui qu'on le veuille ou
non fait partie de la France à part
entière la vraie connerie pardon c'est
de dire on va lui enlever la citoyenneté
française enfin c'est ridicule et on lui
remet enfin efface ça c'est vraiment
ridicule est-ce qu'ils vont pouvoir
durer jusqu'au régional avec ce débat
sur la burqa un problème c'est que la
droite et l'UMP une partie de l'UMP a
essayé d'instrumentaliser le débat sur
la burqa pour redonner vie à un débat
sur immensité nationale qui est devenu
quoi il n'aura aucune aucun débouché ils
vont faire un rapport
remis par les préfectures ça n'a ni que
ni tête et quand on parle justement de
la stigmatisation des de la communauté
musulmane je pense que l'une des erreurs
de la gauche c'est de vouloir renvoyer
toujours les enfants finalement des
catégories populaires les enfants
d'immigrés de les renvoyer de les
assigner à résidence religieuse de les
assigner à résidence Islam de les
assigner à le fait qu'ils sont musulmans
mais il y a plein de jeunes filles et de
jeunes garçons d'ailleurs qui ont envie
qu'on les définissent tout autrement que
comme musulman ou musulmane et en plus
on fait la Mali gamme aujourd'hui entre
la burqa et l'islam ce qui est encore
une nouvelle monstruosité donc parlons
des questions sociales parlons des
discriminations sociales que subissent
ces jeunes dans certaines quartiers
issus de la banlieue qui ne trouvent pas
de boulot parce qu'il s'appelle Mohamed
ou Malik et eux ils le vivent comme du
racisme comme de la xénophobie et c'est
insupportable et pour ça il faut se
battre et donc c'est contre ça que la
gauche doit se battre
et c'est cela d'ailleurs qui souvent se
replie il y a une attitude de repli
parce que justement il n'arrive pas à
avoir de boulot il se replie vers le en
islam radical dure pour parler de 30
secondes encore de la burqa je veux dire
à présent vous avez une fille qui n'est
pas obligée de la porter par son père
par son frère ou par son mari et qui
décide de porter la burqa en quoi ça
vous dérange je veux dire c'est quand
même excusez-moi c'est quand même de
l'ethnocentrisme on veut imposer au
reste du monde notre façon de voir notre
universalisme qu'est-ce qui nous prouve
qu'on a raison d'abord il y a une
question d'indécence vis-à-vis de toutes
les femmes en Afghanistan au Pakistan en
Iran en Algérie toutes ces femmes qui se
battent aujourd'hui pour le droit des
femmes dans tous ces pays et qui ont
tellement de mal à être reconnu
simplement comme citoyenne il y a une
forme de scandale absolue dans le fait
que ici en France il y ait certaines
filles qui puissent se permettre de
revendiquer le port de la burka
deuxième chose c'est
on n'a pas le droit si vous vous voulez
vous promener tout nu dans la rue demain
vous n'avez pas le droit de le faire il
y a des règles lorsqu'une femme se
promène voilée de la tête aux pieds
c'est pas seulement le problème de cette
femme qui porte la burqa c'est le
problème de tous les gens de tous les
jeunes les jeunes filles les jeunes
garçons de tous les hommes et les femmes
qu'elle va croiser ce sont eux aussi qui
sont insultés qui sont agressés dans
leur dignité
sur la tête et si je vais me balader
dans la rue qu'est-ce qu'on peut me dire
tomber dans la drogue monsieur pour tout
le monde imagine Ardisson à poil avec un
drap mais
donne-moi les SCOOP je prends les photos
on partage l'argent pour d'abord il faut
dire une chose c'est que il n'y avait
pas de burqa en dehors de l'Asie
centrale et notamment d'Afghanistan il y
a encore 20 ou 30 ans et de plus en plus
maintenant y compris dans les pays
musulmans
de l'Égypte je veux dire jusqu'au Maroc
vous trouvez maintenant des burcas des
femmes qui sont dans des prisons en
toile ça c'est la première chose la
deuxième chose c'est que ce qui est
terrible dans la burqa c'est c'est la
négation de l'autre c'est-à-dire vous
n'y est les autres avec une burqa vous
êtes enfermé vous me dites chez vous
mais quand chez moi
je suis pour la liberté absolue et je
pense que là c'est une atteinte je suis
désolé à la liberté des gens en se
balade comme on veut la liberté absolue
mais quand c'est une liberté qui libère
et là je suis désolé le port de la burqa
c'est une fausse liberté parce qu'en
fait c'est une liberté qui opprime
ça n'existe pas
c'est 68 + 77
à partir de 80 ans
[Applaudissements]
bon moi j'aurais revenir sur quelque
chose que Marc Levy a dit tout à l'heure
qui me paraît important certes la burqa
c'est pas un symbole religieux et le
Coran ne recommande pas le port de la
burqa
simplement ce qu'il faut se dire c'est
que aujourd'hui il y a des personnes qui
se servent de la religion comme d'une
provocation bon et la plupart de ceux
qui portent la burqa qui sont français
qui beaucoup sont convertis
adoptent cette cette accoutrement pour
provoquer et il le provoque au nom d'un
islam que la grande majorité la très
grande majorité des musulmans condamnent
vous venez dire quand même excuse-moi
vous dire accoutrement c'est un terme
colonialiste à coutrement mais si je
vous le dis mais je vous le dis comment
ça me rappelle les colons qui disaient
regardez ces indigènes leur accoutrement
non mais si vous pouvez pas savoir à
quel point l'animateur est dans la merde
qu'en 4 personnes sont d'accord
[Applaudissements]
il y a un truc pour finir quand même
qu'il faut dire c'est qu'avenue
Montaigne dans les boutiques de luxe on
accepte les femmes en burqa parce que
c'est des princesses d'Arabie Saoudite
évidemment vous l'intérêt de d'interdire
aussi sur la voie publique d'accord très
bien on continue notre commentaire de
l'actualité de la semaine avec les
vitaux de Blacko 2
[Musique]
voilà un patron qui accepte de baisser
son salaire de 22% et on continue de le
clouer au pylori alors qu'il touche 6
fois moins d'argent que Johnny
[Musique]
bon un million 600000 euros par an ça
nous fait quand même 7000 euros par jour
n’empêche c'est presque moitié moi que
les 3 millions de poussent Ben Arfa à
l'OM l'OM là embauché en pensant que
c'était le nouveau Zidane hors depuis le
début du championnat combien il a marqué
de buts 0 tandis que Broglio lui c'est
le Zidane du CAC 40 la preuve il est
capable de jouer dans plusieurs équipes
à la fois il est PDG de DS mais il est
aussi au conseil d'administration de
Veolia à celui de Natixis de Lagardère
de CNP de Dassault Aviation un surhum de
cet envergure ça n'a pas de prix alors
évidemment si on précise que Proglio
touche plus de 100 fois le SMIC il y a
de quoi être indigné mais attention le
smicard français lui aussi est un
privilégié le SMIC en France
7 fois plus élevé que le SMIC en
Roumanie alors dit comme ça il y a pas
le choix si on veut que la France reste
compétitive
il faut embaucher des patrons roumains
bah oui ils seront certainement cette
fois moins cher voilà c'était l'élite de
Blacko mise en images de Julien gras
voilà moi quand j'ai su le salaire de
prolio j'ai éteint la lumière
franchement
alors là bon il a abandonné ce qui
venait de chez Veolia mais quand même
c'est parce qu'il était obligé quoi là
où il y a vraiment en matière à
polémiquer ce qui est un peu scandaleux
c'est la façon dont ça s'est passé c'est
pas du tout le salaire oui pour moi il y
a deux choses qui sont incroyables c'est
que un même homme puisse à la fois
diriger une entreprise publique et une
entreprise privée ces deux entreprises
privées je m'en fous la liberté du
marché et là c'est une entreprise
publique qui est pas n'importe laquelle
parce qu'elle a quand même des enjeux
importants y compris nucléaires donc il
peut y avoir des conflits d'intérêts la
deuxième chose c'est quand même le
mensonge enfin pas le mensonge mais la
dissimulation de la présentation
gouvernementale qui dit non on vous
promet
il aura le même salaire quand il était à
Veolia mais il cumulera pas de salaires
on l'a obligé à se contredire je pense
qu'ils étaient très emmerdés avec cette
histoire et c'est pour ça qu'il dégonfle
le ballon très vite parce que ça ça
aurait plutôt aussi un populaire que
l'affaire de Jean Sarkozy et on voit
bien que prolio en fait le vrai problème
c'est que c'est avant tout un homme de
Veolia avant d'être le nouveau patron de
DF qui serait de rapprocher Veolia et
EDF le risque c'est que finalement avec
un homme à la tête des deux entreprises
à terme on arrive à une sorte de
fusionner à l'Assemblée nationale il
nous a dit jamais de mon vivant je ne
laisserai nationaliser Veolia je lui ai
dit mais est-ce que vous laisseriez
privatiser EDF et il a pas répondu ah
donc on voit bien le risque c'est ça
c'est ça entre les deux entreprises au
moment où on annonce qu'on va augmenter
les tarifs de l'électricité au même
moment le patron d'EDF il va augmenter
son salaire de 45%. j'ai lu dans la
presse que on envisageait d'augmenter
les tarifs en période de surconsommation
d'électricité donc ça veut dire quand il
fait très froid et je me demande si
quand on pense à ça on imagine ou nombre
de gens qui ont des moyens extrêmement
restreints qui vont qui vont de plus
pouvoir se chauffer là
l'électricité c'est un service public
parce que finalement le sentiment qui
prédomine c'est pas que les grands
patrons finalement ne subissent pas les
effets de la crise quand on voit que
Didier Lombard à la tête de France
Télécom il va toucher encore cette année
un million six d'euros on peut pas dire
que ce qui s'est passé à France Télécom
soit une grande réussite ni sociale ni
économique on sait
anglo-saxonner c'est-à-dire qu'on s'est
mis à la hauteur des Anglo-Saxons en se
disant on va perdre nos patrons si on
leur donne pas autant que les autres on
devrait faire une prime à l'emploi pour
les grands patrons oui c'est vrai au
lieu qu'il soit rémunérés
il faudrait créer une forme de conflit
d'intérêt entre leur obligation de
servir leurs actionnaires et que
là-dessus il soit beaucoup moins
rémunéré mais qu'un
patrones
qu'un patron qui crée un million
d'emplois gagne un million d'euros bravo
bah voilà c'est une très bonne on
appellera ça la loi marque Lévy au
revoir merci merci d'être venu je suis
très content de vous avoir et nous
accueillons notre invité du samedi 20h
ce soir Cécile Hernandez Cervelo
pour ces livres témoignages consacré à
la sclérose en plaques alors Cécile
bonsoir vous êtes atteint donc de
sclérose en plaques vous êtes ici ce
soir pour pousser un coup de gueule car
depuis que tout le monde sait que
Dominique Farrugia lui-même est atteint
de cette maladie plus personne ne prend
votre maladie au sérieux
ça serait bien ça c'est dommage est-ce
que quand vous avez contracté cette
maladie vous avez contracté le même rire
que faire
30 ans et j'ai commencé à rire comme ça
alors on en reparle à 20h en attendant
j'accueille Stéphane Guillon
[Applaudissements]
alors c'est pas la semaine Thierry c'est
toute l'année 2010 absolument
et on commence janvier 2010 on commence
avec une nouvelle étonnante le docteur
delajou qui ne trouvait plus aucun
patient depuis son opération sur Johnny
s'est reconverti dans la boucherie la
boucherie de la joue les clients sont
satisfaits les beaux gosses super sympa
en revanche la viande est très mal
découpée cette dame qui avait commandé
une côte de boeuf s'est retrouvé qu'un
steak haché
[Applaudissements]
février 2010 le 15 exactement une
terrible nouvelle qui a ébranlé tout le
département de la Moselle Rachida Dati
s'est suicidé elle nous avait prévenu en
décembre dernier si vous me laissez à
Strasbourg ça finira par un drame
promesse tenue Rachida s'est pendu avec
sa tenue préférée un ensemble Dior
qu'elle avait porté à la Maison Blanche
j'ai voulu finir en beauté et critel je
laisse Zora au bon soin de Bernard
Laporte
préparer toutes les boutiques de luxe
resteront fermées en signe de deuil
[Applaudissements]
mars 2010 trions du Front national aux
élections régionales 15% des voix Marine
Le Pen remercie
Eric Besson c'est débats sur l'identité
nationale on décomplexé l'opinion
eric est un merveilleux attaché de
presse merci mille fois bisous Marie
[Applaudissements]
avril 2010 DSK volontaire pour la
castration chimique une décision
mûrement réfléchie pour la
présidentielle de 2012 je veux être
totalement concentré sur ma tâche et ne
plus être sans cesse dérangé par mes
pulsions c'est bien ouais c'est bien
juin 2010 le 22 exactement la France
éliminé du Mondial
on rentre à la maison dès le premier
tour on rentre à la maison après avoir
perdu ces trois premiers matchs pour des
raisons de sécurité Thierry Raymond
Domenech préfère ne pas rentrer en
France le sélectionneur s'installe
définitivement en Afrique du Sud
juillet Sylvie oberlusconian à nouveau
des figuré cette fois-ci c'est une
prostituée milanaise qui lui a balancé
une lampe de chevet le docteur delajou
propose de quitter sa boucherie pour une
opération de la dernière chance refus
catégorique des Italiens on préfère
encore qui ressemble à une vieille
mozzarella
août 2010 la joie de Nicolas Sarkozy au
Cap [__] après trois années de bagarre
de réunion de copropriété houleuses le
président obtient que toutes les villas
du Cap soit reliées au tout-à-l'égout on
l'écoute
écouter
c'est une très belle victoire
toutes ces odeurs qui refoulaient dans
un endroit paradisiaque c'est
insupportable là on va enfin pouvoir
entendre le champ des griots sans être
importuner puis je voudrais dire
qu'après la branlée qu'on a prise aux
élections régionales remporter quelque
chose ça fait plaisir je vous laisse je
continue mon footing
septembre 2010 Jean Sarkozy triple sa
première année de droit
chapeau s'exclame Isabelle Balkany Jean
se donne tellement à la politique qu'il
sacrifie ses études beaucoup trop
brillant pour végéter dans une faculté
renchérie sorte feu Frédéric Lefebvre
lui dénonce une chasse aux sorcières le
fils d'un génie politique devrait passer
automatiquement dans la classe
supérieure
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
octobre grande victoire pour les Afghans
la Cimade et toutes les associations des
droits de l'homme Éric Besson né au
Maroc réussi à expulser lui-même
[Applaudissements]
novembre 2010 le bonheur de Roselyne
Bachelot lors d'un voyage au Pérou la
ministre de la Santé a découvert la
grippe du lama
celle-ci pourrait frapper la France dès
2011 le malade pris de fortes fièvres
crache tout ce qu'il avale à la tête de
ses proches
décembre 2010 drame en plein Téléthon
l'homme d'affaires Pierre Berger qui
avait été invité pour faire son mea
culpa c'est brutalement précipité sur un
groupe de myopathes pour crever les
roues de leur fauteuil à l'aide d'un
tournevis Gérard rolls pensant qu'il
s'agissait d'un exercice pour récolter
des dons a mis plus de 5 minutes à
réagir Pierre Berger s'engage à
rembourser plus de 43 chambres à air
voilà voilà
[Applaudissements]
que vous retrouvez ici la semaine
prochaine et d'ici là sur
canal+.fr on passe maintenant à notre
invité du samedi matin
[Musique]
Cécile rebondsoir dans votre premier
livre La guerre des nerfs publiée au
rocher en 2008 vous racontez votre
maladie et dans votre deuxième livre
qu'est-ce qu'elle fait maman au rocher
en 2009 vous racontez votre maternité
c'est assez fort on va prendre les
choses au commencement vous êtes né en
1974 à Perpignan vos parents se séparent
rapidement votre père assez ambitieux
assez carriéristes s'installe à
l'étranger et votre mère se sacrifie
pour que vous fassiez des études et du
sport voilà effectivement pendant votre
adolescence vous devenez une championne
de BMX faites des compétitions
championnats de France et aussi au
niveau international
Europe et Championnat du Monde
championnats du monde
alors pareil pour les études faites un
de sciences du langage bac + 5 bon voilà
là vous créez une société de
communication événementielle
spécialisée dans les sports extrêmes qui
organise le festival alternatif des
sports tendances le Fast et en parallèle
vous créez une marque de textile voilà
donc vous êtes une
Wonder Woman et là le 21 octobre 2002
tout bascule à 8h du matin le téléphone
sonne je me lève mes jambes ne
fonctionnent plus je tombe et je suis
paralysée des membres inférieurs
c'est le drame je comprends pas pourquoi
mes jambes ne fonctionnent pas et matin
donc j'ai essayé une nouvelle fois
nouvelle échec vous paniquez vous criez
vous pleurez vous comprenez pas ce qui
se passe et vous écrivez mon poids plume
47 kg devient un poids mort je suis
allongée sur le sol à ne plus à essayer
de m'accrocher à ma couette au bord de
mon lit pour me soulever et je n'arrive
pas à me alors dans l'ambulance vous
dites je déteste mon corps à morphe il
me trahit vous allez à l'hôpital oui je
suis un légume vide et immobile
catapulté dans un monde blanc stérile et
chloroforme
dans votre bouquin je ne sais pas ce
qui se passe dans un box où il y a
même Laden ouais c'est ça
c'est vrai moi qui suis en panique parce
que je griffe je me pince et je ne sens
toujours pas mes jambes voilà le médecin
vous examine effectivement vous dites je
n'ai senti ni les mains de ce docteur
sur mes membres ni les petites aiguilles
qu'il a planté dans mes mollets et mes
orteils je suis paralysé et vous savez
toujours pas de quoi
les examens sont nombreux pénibles c'est
toute la toute l'horreur hospitalière
quoi vous êtes trimballé d'un service à
l'autre pendant 4 jours seul parce
qu'évidemment aux urgences on n'a pas le
droit à la famille après j'ai été
transférée en soins intensifs et puis on
m'avait déjà fait des premiers examens
on ne donne pas les résultats de ces
premiers examens et puis il y a une
surenchère d'examen et bon vous savez
toujours pas et finalement le jeudi
alors vous êtes là depuis le Lundi vous
voyez le médecin qui parle à votre mère
mais à l'extérieur de votre chambre là
où j'ai compris qu'il y avait quelque
chose maman c'est mordu la lèvre pour ne
pas pleurer parce que dans l'imbrasure
de la porte je voyais le médecin et
maman de profil et là je comprends
quelque chose de grave
sclérose en plaques
au début vous comprenez pas très bien je
n'ai jamais entendu parler de la
Sclérose En plage j'associe ça une
maladie de peau et je comprends pas rien
en fait le mot plaque signifie les
lésions donc c'est une atteinte du
système nerveux central cerveau plus la
moelle épinière et c'est l'inflammation
d'une substance grasse qui protège les
nerfs
électriques c'est la moelle épinière et
autour il y a une gaine il y a des trous
dans la gaine donc les trousses font les
toutes les fils se touchent et ça nous
voilà ça t'empêche de voir
de marcher de te servir de tes mains
alors c'est une maladie évolutive
dégénérative
ça ne s'arrête plus
alors vous dites effectivement
je suis handicapé moi qui était
l'indépendance personnifiée vous dites
[__] c'est impossible j'ai pas me
retrouver sur un fauteuil roulant
c'est-à-dire que ça vous chope en plein
vol quoi moi je dis je vis avec un point
d'interrogation je ne sais pas pourquoi
je suis malade je ne sais pas comment
elle va évoluer
je vais pas demain comment je vais me
réveiller alors évidemment vous devenez
un peu exécrable un peu
agressive avec vos proches mais il y a
de la patience module la Frédéric
alors vous dites je suis rongé par la
haine de la vie quoi c'est à dire qu'à
un moment vous vous rebellez
complètement contre cette situation il y
a eu un moment après le diagnostic où
j'ai vraiment sombré dans une phase très
négative où j'ai pensé au suicide etc
vous êtes au fond du trou et vous
décidez de remarcher quoi c'est vous
dites ça va être mon nouveau challenge
alors vous commencez le cocktail
rééducation plus psychanalyse assez
courageusement
sportif de haut niveau j'avais quand
même des ressources
musculature mais aussi la volonté que ce
que sont les heures d'entraînement là en
l'occurrence mon entraînement c'est les
heures de kiné puisque j'étais en centre
de rééducation pendant 11 mois après le
diagnostic le neurone avait dit c'est
pas sûr que vous pourriez avoir un jour
mais moi je savais que je remarcherais
un pire sing sur la lèvre c'est assez
parce que vous avez encore la marque et
en fait je voulais que les gens arrêtent
de focaliser leur attention sur mon
fauteuil roulant ou sur mes béquilles et
qui voit quelque chose d'encore plus
choquant à l'époque c'était une barre en
fer qui dépassait de manière quand on
regarde mon visage et non plus mes
jambes mon fauteuil ou mes cannes merci
et là vous tombez enceinte c'est là où
quand même l'histoire devient
extraordinaire c'est à dire c'est pas
facile de tomber enceinte vous essayez
pendant un long moment j'ai arrêté donc
mon traitement pour ce projet de bébé le
11 janvier 2006 le 11 janvier 2007 j'ai
su que j'étais enceinte euh non
c'est pas héréditaire la sclérose en
plaques donc il y a pas de problème
voilà alors la fille vous l'avez appelé
quand même victoire et Léonore mais oui
c'est une
victoire c'est pas c'est pas une
revanche c'est une victoire
à ce moment-là j'ai une mère ordinaire
avant votre maladie vous pensiez que la
maternité allez vous éloigner de votre
réussite professionnelle vous aviez pas
trop envie d'avoir des enfants non du
tout un enfant c'est un frein à mes
ambitions professionnelles en fait il y
a un avant le 21 octobre 2002 et Anna
frais et j'ai voulu ce bébé et là vous
faites ce bouquin donc pour expliquer à
votre fille pourquoi pourquoi ta mère
elle a une cam parce que moi il y a pas
de ta bouille il y a pas de secret de
famille elle a deux ans et 4 mois donc
elle est consciente sa maman pourrait
c'est elle est indissociable de la canne
parce que j'ai besoin de marcher la
petite elle a deux ans et 4 mois elle me
dit la sept ça pue elle me dit elle me
dit la sève c'est pas magnifique maman
c'est dit non c'est pas magnifique mais
c'est comme ça on peut pas refaire une
histoire il faut vivre avec tu vas vivre
avec ton papa va vivre avec donc c'est
comme ça
[Applaudissements]
Dominique vous aussi vous avez fait un
enfant en tout cas j'ai une petite fille
qui est un peu plus petite qui a qui
s'appelle Mia qui quand elle voit ma
canne par terre elle dit papa et elle
prend la canne elle me l'a dit c'est
pareil
des enfants par exemple quand je vais
chercher à la crèche à la garderie et
qu'elle voit des enfants s'approcher
elle a du mal parce qu'elle a
l'impression que maman ne pourra pas
s'occuper d'elle si elle n'a pas cet
artifice c'est cet accessoire c'est la
canne la recherche on est où Dominique
aujourd'hui parce que je sais que vous
militez beaucoup évidemment et vous vous
donnez beaucoup de mal pour ça et c'est
très louable on va dans le bon sens
c'est à dire que d'une part ce qu'on est
en train de s'injecter tous les jours il
y a des gens qui travaillent dessus pour
que ça devienne un médicament
c'est-à-dire juste une pilule à prendre
déjà c'est un changement énorme c'est de
se piquer tous les matins moi je veux
faire au bout d'un moment tu en as marre
quoi alors travailler aussi sur le moyen
de ne pas avoir à se déplacer vers le
médecin et ça par exemple en Israël aux
techniques en ce moment on travaille sur
un truc formidable c'est comment tu peux
être chez toi avec une webcam parler
avec un neurologue qui est lui à l'autre
bout du à l'autre bout du monde et avoir
une vraie consultation comme dans comme
dans un cabinet il faut penser d'abord
au malade il y a parmi les malades 80%
en France 80% des malades sont au
chômage
c'est une maladie qui te désocialise
c'est à dire que comme tu as du mal à
marcher tu as du mal à descendre de chez
toi et ben plus petit à petit tu n'es
plus rien et c'est donner la chance aux
malades de rester dans la vie et pas
hors la vie mais Dominique comment vous
faites pour pour concilier cette maladie
donc avec une vie aussi active parce que
vous êtes pas arrêté là j'ai des
esclaves non
et un fouet je ne paye pas bien sûr je
suis un [__]
quand on littéraire c'est le travail qui
me donne la force de faire ce que je
fais alors c'est vrai là en ce moment
j'ai une tendinite de la hanche qui me
fait mal de chien donc je manque de
tomber je marche comme un abruti ça
m'énerve profondément je m'arrête pas
parce que c'est mon moteur
est une maladie dont on ne parle pas
assez qui touche donc on disait 80 000
personnes en France toutes les quatre
heures on en trouve
mais surtout des
accents au dessus des jeunes les gens
très jeunes des jeunes adultes la
première cause chez les jeunes après
accidents de la route
c'est énorme c'est énorme quelqu'un qui
termine ses études qui fait la fête et
qui le lendemain comme ça n'arrive plus
à marcher c'est voilà c'est absolument
terrible et aussi il y a un truc dingue
c'est que on a peur de déclarer sa
maladie au travail de peur de se faire
virer c'est-à-dire qu'on va cacher ça
pendant des mois voire des années
souffrir le martyre en silence de peur
de se servir et de pas le dire aux
autres c'est terrible parce que si tu es
malade tu es viré il faut que le regard
change sur le handicap c'est un de mes
combats aussi parce que parce que les
gens quand ils me croisent ils se disent
pas que je suis handicapé ils se disent
que je peux avoir ce que je peux avoir
une entorse ou quoi que ce soit mais il
faut faire changer le regard sur le
handicap
merci d'avoir été avec voilà c'est du
Salut les Terriens avec Marc Levy pour
la première nuit ici Robert Laffont
merci
Aurélie Filippetti
député PS de Moselle Dominique Farrugia
que nous retrouvons pour l'amour c'est
mieux à deux quand même c'est gentil
Yves très rare du Figaro
et Cécile hernandel Cervelo
qu'est-ce qu'elle fait maman rocher
je lui remercier tous ceux qui ont
manifesté leur soutien à nos deux SDF de
la semaine dernière
Justine et Nicolas qui sont logés avenue
Hoche
[Musique]
ils ont une chambre à venir
c'est un ami qui s'appelle Daniel D et
qui a un délicatesse de pas vouloir
qu'on cite son nom voilà je vous laisse
avec mes amis d'Action discrète et de
Groland merci à toute l'équipe qui m'a
aidé à préparer cette émission
rendez-vous samedi prochain Salut les
Terriens
[Applaudissements]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
Inna larditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu